OK, let's go next to Eduardo from Brooklyn,
Eduardo from Brooklyn.
You're on the air.
Hi, David.
Hi, how are you?
A good big fan, thanks for doing this.
Thank you.
Quick question for you, though, is so is the
vaccines kind of become a little more readily
available?
I was wondering, is there going to be sort
of sort of like a like a paperwork that you
have to show that you've been vaccinated or
some sort of badge or whatever?
I assume so, yeah, we've already heard so
the airline, Qantas has already said they
will be requiring a vaccination certificate
after a certain point if you want to fly with
them.
Ticketmaster has said they are building infrastructure
so that any any sports or concert venue that
wants to sell tickets with them will be able
to require a vaccination certificate.
In some cases, it's a vaccination certificate
or a negative test within, you know, a certain
amount of time before the event.
I, I am hopeful that some American Airlines
will say after a certain date you need a vaccination
certificate.
I don't know if it will be administered at
the federal or state level.
There will be people, Eduardo, who will say
this is mandated vaccination.
And of course, it's not.
It's only if you choose to avail yourself
of certain private business services, you
need to be vaccinated.
And I think it's going to be necessary to
get more people vaccinated.
40 percent reportedly don't want the vaccine.
And that's a real problem.
Do you do you reckon, though, that if like
that can be sort of like extended to sort
of like a localized situation, like bars and
restaurants and stuff like that?
It certainly could be, but my instinct is
that, you know, an individual bar or business
is unlikely to pursue that.
That's my sense.
I think it'll be, you know, airlines, maybe
some schools and, you know, employers could
do it.
If you're a really big employer, like a Wal-Mart,
for example, you could say, listen, we don't
want our employees falling ill nor our customers
getting the virus from employees.
So after a certain date, if you want to work
with us, you need to have a vaccination.
That's certainly something a private employer
could do.
I'd be shocked, shocked if, like, individual
restaurants did it.
Sure, yeah, I mean, for that, we need the
vaccine for us and we need the vaccine first
and, you know, hopefully we are we are three
weeks from it.
Fair enough.
Thanks, David, and keep doing what you do.
All right, Eduardo from Brooklyn.
Great questions.
Vaccine talk.
Love it.
Love the vaccine.
The vaccine is coming.
And that is you know, that is something we're
all going to have to contend with.